hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the comic and
ethics book six Aristotle discusses the
intellectual virtues and names of five
of them one of them is prudence and
towards the end of the work Aristotle
the end of that book
Aristotle was going to discuss for us
several other qualities of mind that he
considers to be good in helping us to to
find practical or theoretical truth and
one of these is what we call in English
excellence in deliberation the Greek
word for that is a luleå which literally
means deliberating well or or well
deliberation and why is this so
important well deliberation will ASUS or
bullion or bullying is playing a major
role as we've seen in prudence and also
in phronesis or deliberate or moral
choice which Aristotle actually defines
at one point as deliberative desire so
being able to deliberate well you can
see how that quality would would really
substantively aid moral decision-making
orienting us towards the good all these
sorts of things that that are important
in ethics he starts out by as you often
does asking well could be this thing or
this thing or this thing and he proposes
three candidates three types of things
that deliberating well could be one of
them is knowledge or scientific
knowledge at piston a another one is
opinion or dopes um and the third one is
we call skill and conjecture that's sort
of a rough translation and it was okiya
or as he's been too closely connected
with another thing that's this related
spirit monkey knowing a meaning the
ability to to you know it's sort of
intuitively or immediately grasped the
middle term that's required in figuring
things out Arizona's going to say that
excellence and deliberation is not any
of these and he's going to provide us
with some reasons for that
when it comes to knowledge you're pissed
amazed there's a couple things right off
the bat we don't actually deliberate
about things that we already know
because then we wouldn't need to
deliberate about them so it can't
actually be knowledge another problem is
that knowledge strictly speaking can't
be false you don't have false mal that
you just have thinking that you know
something when you when you actually
don't whereas we can deliberate badly we
can arrive at the wrong conclusion in
deliberation and we also arrive at the
the right conclusion so that's not going
to be you know a very good candidate
what about an opinion opinion could be
right or could be wrong it seems as if
perhaps opinion could be the same thing
as deliberating well you just have the
right opinions and you throw them out
there and now you're done with your
process of reasoning and Aristotle says
well no that's part of the problem
opinion sort of has things settled for
it already it's not still seeking it's
got some some belief in place could be
wrong belief
that it's a belief nonetheless so
opinion itself is not going to be
excellence in deliberation what about
this skill in conjecture that's probably
a better candidate isn't it because
there it seems like we're talking about
is a process of figuring things out well
it has to do with the immediacy or the
median Ness you might say of this that
helps to see that it's not skill in
conjecturing says skill and conjecture
operates without conscious calculation
without using logos and rapidly whereas
deliberate intends to take a long time
he says there's a saying that execution
should be swift but deliberation slow he
says it's also not the same thing as
skill in conjunction so if it's not
those things what could it be
Aristotle if that tells us quite a bit
about it he says that it does involve
investigating right seeking something
out quite literally say TASIS and
reasoning he uses the word for to reason
things out or you know also it's been
translated as to calculate locates at
logee's aside to use logos to use reason
to try to you know differentiate things
to figure out the means required for
ends to weigh those means against each
other and look for any other sort of
outcomes that might happen because of
that
so the deliberation involves these
things what else he says that also if
it's going to be excellence in
deliberation involves some sort of
correctness or thought ace is is the
Greek for that in thinking so what would
this what would this consistent
Aristotle points out several ways in
which thinking can go off the rails and
if it's not doing
this is the impression that he gives us
then it's going to be excellence in
deliberation so he's specifying for us
conditions under which this sort of
deliberative puzzling things out which
is really practical reasoning fails or
it were works poorly and saying if it
doesn't do those things then it's
actually on track so what are the ways
in which things can go wrong well does
it arrive at something that's genuinely
good aristotle points out a very
interesting problem here he says that
there we go
a man of deficient self-restraint that
is a chronic person or a bad person
may as a result of calculation arrive at
the object he proposes as the right
thing to do so it's quite possible to
arrive at some sort of conclusion you
know your your reasoning is considered
on its face valid or strong you didn't
make any dumb mistakes along the way but
as we you know the old saying goes in
computer programming garbage in garbage
out if you begin with wrong premises
then you're going to end up with you who
knows where I mean you could end up in a
good conclusion but quit bluffing you're
not going to and why does it matter if a
person is lacking self-control or is a
genuinely bad person well in the case of
the person lacking self-control it's
actually the passions that are deciding
things for them or a deficient line of
reasoning that they don't they don't
quite grasp we'll talk about that in a
separate video in the case of the bad
person they actually are beginning from
the wrong starting points because they
think some things are good that aren't
actually good so the vicious person
believes that what they're doing is
reasonable is is good is steering them
towards something and if they are you
know deliberating well it's not still
yet
in deliberation because it's getting
them to the wrong place alternately in
order for it to be good deliberation and
he has to get them to the right place so
what else could go into this if the
premises could be a problem we can also
have the process of inference itself
being a problem and he says that it
can't involve bad or false processes of
reasoning he actually frames this in
terms of picking the wrong middle term
why does he talk in terms of the middle
term because when we're using a
syllogism and this is one of the ways in
which aerosol thinks about reasoning
taking place there is a middle term that
connects together the various
propositions of the syllogism and allows
the inference to take place so if you
pick the wrong middle term then you're
going to wind up with with bad reasoning
and he says that you can in fact start
with good premises and arrive at the
wrong conclusion he says it's also
possible to write at a good conclusion
as by a false process of reasoning one
may arrive at what is the right thing to
do but not arrive at it on the right
browse by means of the wrong middle term
why isn't that though excellence in
deliberation because it's not just about
winding up in the right place having the
right conclusion it's about the way in
which you get there that determines
whether it's in fact good deliberation
or a practical reasoning why is it
important well if you think about it if
you happen to get things right in this
case even though your reasoning is bad
what happens when you play that bad
reasoning in other cases because you're
going to you're probably going to screw
things up and so we don't have a global
trait there he also talks about the
right amount of time as being something
important he had mentioned before the
goodness or excellent
in deliberation is different than skill
in conjecture which is much more
immediate in its inferences that it
carries out he said well it's a good
thing to take a long time but you don't
want to take forever in carrying out
deliberation he twice in terms of not
only having the right grounds which is
important but doing in it was in the
right amount of time not taking too long
to deliberate being able to actually
arrive at a conclusion
some people get caught up in the
investigation and they never actually
get to the reasoning or they carry out
the reasoning and then they keep on
adding in all sorts of new steps that
requires them to revise their reasoning
at every point if you're doing that you
may as well just make a decision not to
do anything because or just to keep the
status quo because that is in effect
what is going to happen that's not in
fact excellence of deliberation so you
see the criteria adhere that are that
are required for it we could think of
this as not only excellence in
deliberation but excellence in practical
reasoning that is required to get us to
our goods